[Musique]
nous sommes le 13 septembre 2016
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
les invités comme chaque jour du lundi
au jeudi rencontre avec ceux qui font l
actualité aujourd'hui vous entendrez
notamment sonia porot la secrétaire
général de la cgt des yvelines qui
prépare la nouvelle mobilisation contre
la loi travail prévue le 15 septembre
entretient également avec les automnes
et spitz ya elle est à l'origine d'un
clip vidéo diffusé sur internet ses
clips qui entend casser des clichés
autour du rugby féminin
pour débuter nous parlons politique au
lendemain de la fête de l'humanité nous
avons voulu faire le point sur la
situation au parti communiste jean luc
mélenchon qui a quitté le front commun
pour lancer sa france insoumise va-t-il
faire de l'ombre pc comment les
militants réagissent et comment ce
police positionne également la formation
sur les différents sujets d'actualité
pour répondre à ces différentes
questions colette géré gènes qui est la
nouvelle secrétaire départemental du
parti communiste dans les yvelines
bonsoir et bienvenue donc sur ce plateau
comment actuellement se porte le parti
communiste après la fête de l'humanité
des batteries sont rechargées tout va
bien complètement c'était une très belle
fête de l'humanité 2016 une fête qu'on a
voulu sous le signe de la fraternité
après les terribles drames de cet été on
voulait un grand moment populaire un
grand moment de rassemblement
et donc sous le signe de la fraternité
comme je disais et sous le signe de la
solidarité nationale et internationale
aujourd'hui il est une union autour de
pierre laurent j'ai évoqué tout à leur
représentation locale de mélenchon
justement est-ce qu'il ya cette unité
autour de pierre laurent où la question
se porte aussi autour de l'attitude à
adopter avec jean luc mélenchon alors
l'union elle n'existe pas encore cela
dit il y à une union de majorité de
transformation sociale on le voit bien
dans les rues quand on voit la forte
mobilisation contre la loi les conneries
on l'a vu aussi sur la fête de
l'humanité où des centaines de milliers
de personnes se sont déplacées pour
débattre pour parler politique pour on a
vu notamment samedi l'intersyndicale
réunie cette organisation syndicale et
de jeunesse pour parler de la loi
travail et on voit bien que ce fait ce
cette majorité de transformation sociale
existe et qu'il ya qu'il faut maintenant
passer enfin qu'elle a transformé en une
majorité politique pour 2017 donc nous
nous appelons toutes les forces de
gauche hostile à la politique de
français est également jean-luc
mélenchon bien sûr on l'appelle à
revenir à une démarche collective parce
que si on ne fait pas de vin c'est la
droite et l'extrême droite au pouvoir
dans huit mois donc sa stratégie n'est
pas la bonne alors vous voulez le
message que le parti communiste va lui
faire passer sa stratégie c'est son
choix je dirais personnel maintenant
nous on pense que de partir seuls
aujourd'hui c'est dangereux et depuis
les années 30 le parti communiste
français a toujours été à l'initiative
de ce rassemblement quand il ya un
danger
quand l'extrême droite nous guette on le
voit bien avec le front populaire en
1936 on le voit aussi lors on a faim on
a
écrit coécrit le programme national de
la résistance et c'est notre
responsabilité en tant que communiste
d'unir le peuple de gauche de faire
ensemble qu'on écrive ensemble un pacte
d'engagement et donc on appelle jean luc
mélenchon bien sûr à l'écrire avec nous
comme toutes les forces de
transformation sociale pour le pays
parce que notre volonté c'est de gagner
en 2017 et si on est quatre ou cinq
candidats est pas ma foi c'est
un danger que et le rassemblement peut
se faire avec europe ecologie les verts
aussi par exemple bien sûr ceux qui
s'opposent au gouvernement actuel en
quelque sorte bien sûr les frondeurs je
pense à benoît hamon peut-être oui bien
aux gaulois amant également moi je vois
tout ce qui nous ressemble et non pas là
tout ce qui nous différencie certes le
peuple de gauche et divers mais on a su
se rassembler notamment l'ajustement
contre la loi travail on a su se
rassembler contre le projet de déchéance
de nationalité
donc c'est possible
et donc voilà on les appelle à revenir
dans un processus collectif vous êtes la
nouvelle responsable dans le département
du parti communiste juste avant les
vacances de cet été vous avez été élu à
ce poste comment se porte le parti
communiste dans le département en terme
d'adhérents en termes d'engagement alors
on est plus dynamique que jamais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu énormément de 18 ans
justement suite aux mobilisations contre
la loi les conneries on en a eu une
bonne cinquantaine à la fête de
l'humanité
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes sont
venus nous parler remplir notre
questionnaire que demande le peuple
puisque
on va vers les gens beaucoup de
politiques aujourd'hui disent faire de
la politique avec les citoyens mais nous
on le fait on va vers eux on leur
demande ce dont ils ont besoin parce que
là il est essentiel de partir des
besoins de la population
pour pouvoir se rassembler et construire
ce projet commun en 2010 est justement
cette consultation qui s'appelle que
demande le peuple que vous menez
actuellement elle va durer jusqu'à quand
elle consiste en quoi à quoi ça va
servir alors ce donc cette grande
consultation citoyenne vise à former un
front populaire et citoyen pour
justement prendre je dirais pour accéder
au pouvoir en 2017 pour rassembler
toutes les forces de gauche pour partir
d'un programme commun d'impact qu'on
appelle un pacte commun d'engagement
avec toutes les forces de transformation
sociale et donc j'appelle toutes les
personnes engagées dans des luttes que
ce soit dans des syndicats dans des
associations
que ce soit pour les ré pour l'accueil
des réfugiés contre la loi travail mais
aussi pour la culture pour l'éducation à
venir remplir ce questionnaire est donc
on va continuer à le distribuer sur les
marchés aller à la rencontre des gens on
a déjà rencontré deux cent mille
personnes en france et donc le 8 octobre
nous organiserons donc une un compte
rendu de cette de cette grande
consultation citoyenne qui j'espère sera
un outil pour rassembler là vous êtes
sur la construction du programme pour la
présidentielle déjà et puis on imagine
aussi par la suite pour les législatives
qui vont concerneront encore plus
directement vous êtes déjà aussi dans
une étape de stratégie et d'alliances ou
pas j'ai évoqué benoît pour par exemple
s'il se présente une nouvelle fois sur
cette 11e circonscription des yvelines
on peut imaginer que vous partiez
ensemble là encore comme je vous dis on
a exactement la même démarche que pour
les présidentielles
c'est à dire que l'élection législative
qui est une élection qui est trop
oubliée puisqu'elle a lieu cette semaine
après les élections présidentielles et
bien cette campagne doit être mené dès
maintenant et nous allons de la même
manière à la rencontre
du peuple de gauche hostile à françois
hollande à emmanuel macron et manuel
valls à manuel valls pour
pour construire ensemble un programme
qui se veut majouri nous avons parlé
dans un instant de la loi travail avec
cette mobilisation qui se prépare pour
le 15 septembre en deux mots est ce que
vous ferez partie du cortège du 15
septembre bien sûr et j'appelle tout le
monde à nous retrouver à paris jeudi
jeudi je dirais qu'il est encore
possible de changer les choses et il
faut se rappeler par exemple le contrat
première embauche qui a été abrogée
après que
il était édité au journal officiel donc
c'est possible voilà c'est la loi était
votée vous pose penser qu'on peut encore
revenir dessus tu as fait très bien
merci je vous rappelle que vous êtes la
nouvelle secrétaire départemental du
parti communiste dans les yvelines
depuis le mois de juin merci à vous
merci il est donc question de cette loi
travaille à présent le 15 septembre il y
aura cette nouvelle mobilisation nous en
parlions à l'instant après la trêve
estivale les opposants seront pour la
quatorzième fois dans la rue rencontrent
avec sonia porot c'est la secrétaire
général de la cgt 78 au micro de michael
almy d'euros nous sommes avec eux sonia
porot responsable de si j'étais dans les
yvelines nous sommes dans les locaux de
la cgt à trappes sonia porot nous avons
parlé de la loi travail il y aura une
manifestation jeudi est-ce qu'elle sera
suivie cette manifestation alors la
mobilisation est connu depuis
avant l'été un donc on a eu le temps de
préparer parce qu'on n'a pas eu de pause
estivale effectivement le passage en
force une nouvelle fois avec le 49 3 et
l'adoption de la loi
ça c'est sa bouche un petit peu les
perspectives mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on
dit aux salariés dans les diffusions de
tracts dans les entreprises c'est qu'une
loi déjà votée peut toujours être abrogé
qui a aussi toute la bataille sur les
décrets d'application et puis ensuite
sur la mise en oeuvre ou pas par les
entreprises la loi travail elle offre
toute une palette de flexibilité dans
les entreprises mais selon le rapport de
force et les batailles qui seront menées
dans chaque entreprise ça passera ou pas
et comment vous allez vous organiser ici
à saint quentin en yvelines où vous
allez prendre le train pour aller sur
paris voilà donc sur saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un départ collectif en
train dans d'autres endroits du
département c'est des départs en car et
puis on se retrouve tous à paris après
un rassemblement à poissy devant la
permanence du député david douillet il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui vont
participer à ce rassemblement vous avez
déjà des échos ici bas on sait voilà
avec le un peu le nombre de caron sequi
il y aura une mobilisation parce que les
militants qui comprennent le les enjeux
sont mobilisés après il ya toujours des
difficultés à faire va aller les gens
jusqu'à jusqu'à paris on sait que des
gens font grève et ne vont pas forcément
manifester et puis on est quand même
dans une situation où le pouvoir d'achat
est quand même et quand même en berne
donc ça pèse aussi sur la possibilité de
faire grève mais quand même l'opinion
est toujours très majoritairement
opposés à cette loi travail et donc nous
serons ce qu'on essaye de montrer c'est
qu'il ya des choses qui ont été gagnés
par la mobilisation notamment toutes les
avancées pour la jeunesse mais aussi un
certain nombre de reculs sur des
articles de la loi et qu'il faut
simplement continuer la bataille en
faisant le lien avec ce qui se passe
dans les entreprises c'est pas c'est pas
déconnecté du quotidien des entreprises
ou même d administration de la fonction
publique les questions de ton de travail
les questions de rémunérations d'heures
supplémentaires toutes ces choses là
c'est déjà des préoccupations au
quotidien
au delà de la loi travail il y aura
d'autres manifestations dans les mois à
venir le mouvement ne va pas
s'essouffler
c'est c'est un mouvement de longue
haleine mais j'ai envie de dire il a
commencé avant la loi travailler et
continuera après parce que des des lois
des accords ou des mesures voilà qui
flexibilise qui remettent en cause les
garanties collectives et les droits des
représentants du personnel pour défendre
les salariés c'est pas c'est pas la
première donc c'est c'est quand même la
mobilisation la plus importante cette
loi là elle a touché à des choses qui
ont fait un électrochoc chez chez les
salariés
donc voila nous ce qu'on leur dit c'est
voilà venez prenons le temps de
construire ensemble de regarder ce que
la loi elle pourrait avoir comme
conséquence chez vous dans votre
entreprise et comment ensemble on peut
on peut se mobiliser et faire en sorte
que au lieu de se dégrader vos
conditions de travail et de rémunération
s'améliore merci sonia peau
les filles du club de rugby de montigny
le bretonneux font le buzz sur internet
les joueuses ont réalisé un court
métrage pour combattre les préjugés sur
le rugby féminin en plus de détails avec
automne et spéciale est à l'origine du
projet nous avons créé ce prix parce que
on cherchait une façon originale de
recruter
de nouvelles filles et on a vu que ce
qui marche et cette année c'était
beaucoup les vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux et on s'est dit pourquoi est ce
qu'on ferait pas notre vidéo à nous
pour montrer que notre équipe existe et
comment s'est déroulé le tournage très
loin des eaux et on l'a fait en juin on
a eu de la chance il faisait beau et ça
a été très speed mais ton dia me monde a
mis la main à la pâte
s'est très bien passé toutes les filles
ont participé au club quasiment toutes
les filles way en fonction des aléas
personnel mes atouts tels qu'ils
pouvaient venir sont venus et au niveau
du montage du coup c'est vous qui vous
êtes occupé du montage de la
scénarisation du projet également la
scénarisation l'a fait de façon commune
on a fait un travail d'équipé est par
contre le montage c'est moi qui les fais
vu que c'est mon métier voilà c'est plus
facile pour moi de le faire que une qui
n'a pas du tout l'habitude cette vidéo a
été faite vis-à-vis du recrutement mais
également pour combattre les préjugés
est-ce que vous avez été confronté à
certains préjugés depuis vous avez
commencé le rugby à oui on a on est
souvent confronté aux préjugés du rugby
féminin c'est à dire les gens ils
pensent qu au rugby féminin il ya que
des grosses des garçons manqués qu'il
faut être une grosse brute pour jouer au
rugby alors que pas du tout et c'est
vraiment ce que la vidéo montre on veut
casser tous ces clichés que tous les
gabarits sont acceptés qu'il n'y a pas
besoin d'être un gros tas et et un gros
garçon manqué on peut être hyper
féminine
émincer petit ses grandes tombe à sa
place au rugby fait et comment été reçu
la vidéo ici à montigny-le-bretonneux
elle a été très bien reçue
voilà on pense tous nos espoirs dans
cette vidéo pour recruter il ya du
recrutement depuis cette vidéo un petit
peu mais pas passer encore et il y aura
d'autres vidéos à l'avenir peut-être
pour combattre à nouveau les préjugés
peut-être on verra pour l'instant mon
amour pour l'instant il n'y a rien de
prévu après
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités rendez
vous chaque soir du lundi au jeudi 18h15
pour une nouvelle édition mercredi je
recevrai notamment le président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les programmes
se poursuivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]